do you find compelling the simulation
hypothesis as a thought experiment that
we're living in a simulation the
universe is
computational
so we are an example
in a computational world
therefore
it is a simulation doesn't necessarily
mean an experiment by
some high school kid in another world
but it's nonetheless
is taking place in a computational world
and everything that's going on is is
basically
a form of of computation
um
so you really have to define what you
mean by
uh
this whole world being a simulation
well then it's the it's the teenager
that
that makes the video game you know us
humans with our current limited
cognitive capability
have
strived to understand ourselves and we
have
created religions
we think of god
whatever that is
do you think god exists
and if so who is god
i alluded to this before we we started
out with
lots of particles going around
yeah and there's nothing that represents
love
and
creativity
um
and somehow we've gotten into a world
where love actually exists
and that has to do actually with
consciousness because you can't have
love without consciousness
so to me that's god the fact that we
have something where
love where you can be devoted to someone
else and and really feel that
love
that's that's god
and if you look at the old testament
it was actually created by several
different
rabbinates
in there
and that i think
they've identified three of them
one one of them
dealt with god
uh as a person that you can make deals
with and he gets angry and he
wrecks rev uh vengeance on various
people
but two of them actually talk about god
as a symbol of love and peace and
harmony and
so forth
that's how they describe god
and so that's my view of god
not not as a
person in the sky that you can make
deals with
it's whatever the magic that goes from
basic elements
to things like consciousness and love
do you think
one of the things i find extremely
beautiful and powerful is cellular
automata which you also touch on
do you think whatever the heck happens
in cellular automata where interesting
complicated objects emerge
god is in there too
the emergence of love
in this seemingly privileged that's the
goal
of of creating a replicant
is that
they would love you and you would love
them
there wouldn't be much point of doing it
if that didn't happen
but all of it
i guess what i'm saying about cellular
automata is
it's uh primitive building blocks and
they somehow create
beautiful things
is there some deep truth to that
about how our universe works is the the
emergence from simple rules
beautiful complex objects can emerge
is that the thing that made us yeah as
we went through all the six phases of
reality
that's a good way to look at it
it just makes them point to the whole
value of
having a universe
you